congress is working on better  coordination between state and federal  governments in order to stop domestic  terrorism  nevada attorney general aaron ford  testified before the house subcommittee  on intelligence and counterterrorism  ford opened a statement reflecting on  the one october mass shooting and the  standoff at the bundy ranch in bunker  bell  he said we may need to change federal  laws to better prosecute  domestic terrorists there are no easy  fixes  in the fight against domestic terrorism  with the rise of domestic violent  extremism there is no question  that something needs to change so that  we can ensure public safety  ford also said we really need to take a  measured approach  that protects privacy free speech and  the right to bear arms